alors là escudé c'est qu'on ne veut pas
voir s'implanter un peu partout à
montréal on vient de voir le reportage
de matthieu proches animation luc
ferrandez bon choix bonsoir bonsoir
alors c'est quoi pas dans ma cour bompas
proche d'une cour d'école ont le choix
lui que qu'est ce que vous vous dites de
ce débat mais au début et beaucoup de
municipalités au début la légalisation
du cannabis et beaucoup de municipalités
qui ont passé d'arrondir encore passer
des règlements comme celui là on avait
des craintes que lily est par exemple
des vendeurs de drogue s'installe proche
des portes d'avilès des six camps mais
escudé s'était fermé on attend on
s'attendait à ce que ça soit un sorte de
centre de distribution qui intéresserait
le marché noir la petite pègre etc c'est
pas du tout ce qui s'est passé ça se
passe très bien la distribution avec les
scuds ici est-ce que des ccc même
paisible quand on va sur mont royal on
voit une files d'attentes de personnes
quand même ça change notre perception
des consommateurs d'ailleurs on les voit
de tout âges de tous âges de toutes
natures et je ne vois pas pourquoi on
conserve encore des inquiétudes de cette
nature-là bon à niveau là dessus je
rejoins j'ai rejoint le moi j'ai
travaillé là dessus dans mes dernières
années politique et je suis allé visiter
une excusé publiquement je pourrais été
filmée mais j'étais allé voir quel type
de clientèle était là je voulais
comprendre peut-être mois le phénomène
j'ai vu des familles arrivés avec leurs
enfants des enfants 20 ans qui n'est
planifié leur week-end puis choisi
chacun leurs qualités de produits qu'ils
voulaient j'ai vu des gens intéressants
mais j'ai vu aussi des gens de 70 80
jeunes qui allaient chercher des
réguliers de la place mais quand on les
regarde dans les quartiers moi aussi
j'avais peur je me dis qui va arriver là
mais c'est déjà qui font la file des
gens qui travaillent déjà indiqué qu'ils
prennent ce qu'ils ont pu s'en vont chez
eux consomment peu sur place et le fait
de pouvoir je comprends les gens
d'oultremont qui ont eu ces craintes la
comme le quément on les a eus avant mais
là tu n as qui arrivent ceux qui en
veulent pas chez eux mais il ya des gens
chez eux qui vont chercher ailleurs et
pourquoi les fils sont aussi lent dans
les hautes études et c'est parce qu'ils
n'ont pas pu aller en chercher dans leur
quartier perso aussi veulent pas
d'enfant
e
restons calmes respirons par le nez de
20 l'ouverture éventuelle de escudé
c'est bon centre de tri gros sujets
lâcher d'un centre de tri montréal doit
prendre possession mais comme la qualité
n'est pas assez bonne montréal ne prend
pas possession encore et encore des
ratés dans le recyclage le père vous
n'aviez pas dit vous à la radio c'est
l'an dernier quand j'ai vu ce que vous
ne recyclent signé pas vous chanliau
verts voudraient ce que vous avez
recommencé à recycler oui il ya deux ans
et demi j'ai dit je vais arrêter de
rescrit c'est un appel à l'amélioration
du système de recyclage que je faisais
il ya des belles initiatives de
recyclage et des lieux d des efforts qui
sont faits mais il reste des lacunes
majeures et c'est là que deux matches à
aulas ne seront pas réglés par un centre
magique qui va faire le tri parce que on
met trop de choses dans le recyclage de
trop de produits différents qu'ils ne
sont c'est une espèce d'illusion
consumériste de penser qu'on peut faire
mille sortes d'emballages de carton
mélangez alex plastique laminé
vernis etc après ça ils vont se recycler
par magie alors déjà les gens mettent
n'importe quoi dans le recyclage enfin
une porte pour une proportion des gens
mais de les porter pendant leur stage et
ensuite même s'ils font des efforts des
produits eux mêmes ont plusieurs
intrants sont difficiles à recycler
quand le camion arrive le faut voir ça
dans un centre de recyclage 12 tonnes
qui sera en vert sur le convoyeur est là
les gens et c'est dans le ville à lui
minium le plastique etc sa voix une
vitesse folle les ballots qui sort de là
sont loin d'être pur bon alors vous êtes
que la ville de montréal leur région
dans le cas de la chine de ne pas
prendre possession même si la fois où tu
reviens ou citoyens qui met n'importe
quoi dedans mais voilà c'est à dire que
il ya une pensée magique de penser que
le sens de recyclage va faire le tri
dans de toutes sortes de toute forme
avec n'importe quel produit entre un
train ces pauvres et ça ne se produira
pas il faut améliorer à la source ceci
étant dit la ville en raison de ne pas
prendre le centre de recyclage puisque
le sandero stage avait accepté avait
prétendu ça capable de faire ce tri ok
car annie ça revient la responsabilité
citoyenne de promettre n'importe quoi
dans notre sens dans notre bac mais à la
fois à la vie aux citoyens faut se
rappeler que le taux de rejet
actuellement jamais été aussi haut
comparativement aux dernières années
2015 à 2018 la raison et parce qu'ils
ont changé la façon de phase ii dire
qu'avant lui lit le tri se faisait à la
maison donc dans le bac ont été séparés
papier carton métal et verre on est due
à un moment donné pour des coûts ça
coûte moins chansons mais tout en main
tant pis inquiétez pas le centre de tri
va s'en occuper c'est là que ça a
commencé à se faire tout croche avec
évidemment les gens mettent un peu de
tout l'hôte responsabilité c'est ce
qu'ils font les emballages long nez des
emballages de toutes sortes il ya des
choses qui sera si comme le claudie et
des choses qui se recyclent pas donc au
lieu d'avoir 36 sorte de carton
plastifié pour plastifier avec un
certain pourquoi le profèrent des
emballages qui sont légalement
acceptable pour le recyclage je pense
que le gouvernement devrait s'en mêler
aussi en légiférant disant voici le
titre de carton qu'on veut maintenant
voici le type de plastique les autres
types de plastiques seront pas acceptés
il ya comme un travail de fond à refaire
ce que je peux vous dire par contre
j'ai eu des informations en chine il ya
entre autres une entreprise qui fait du
recyclage lui l'entreprise fait le
recyclage et la transformation
son taux de ré g et 2 0% il peut
construire est gelée vu construire une
maison à partir de ce qu'ils ramassent
en recyclage donc du papier voiliers
vont être capables par du plancher du
bois il construit une maison au complet
avec les produits de recyclage zéro
déchet zéro ruff nous ici on est en
parallèle à la rue derrière on n'est pas
capable trouvé beaucoup de développement
pour nos produits aient encore des
jeunes et si je peux me permettre de ça
ça va être du passé par devrait y avoir
de la réglementation alors
réglementation sur d'une part des
intrants dont une uniformisation des
emballages réglementation aussi sur les
extras en ce moment une entreprise qui
fait des produits en plastique au point
un intérêt à acheter du plastique il est
moins pur il est plus cher que du site
du plastique qui est fait dans des
usines qui co derrière des fortunes qui
fonctionne au père noël et choisir des
investissements de plusieurs milliards
de dollars dans des usines de plastique
créé un plastique pas cher est de bonne
qualité alors si on veut utiliser le
plastique il faut qu'on qui contraignent
aussi au niveau de la production plastic
première chose il faut il faut aussi
poussé beaucoup sur toutes les formes
locales d'utilisation par exemple le
vert lover on peut pas juste se
contenter de dire on va s'en servir
servir comme épandage pour couper les
odeurs dans les dépotoirs il faut
vraiment qu'on récupère de verre la
consigne devrait nous aider à faire ça
l'autre le bât blesse c'est vraiment le
papier le carton ça va assez bien le
verre on pense qu'avec la consigne ça va
s'améliorer le papier le plastique là
c'est vraiment là où ça va mal et le
papier constitue une part très
importante du recyclage alors il faut se
concentrer sur le papier très bien
cabane dans un arbre pourquoi les
muncipalités pensez vous que je parle de
pointe claire on embête un monsieur qui
a fait une belle cabane parce qu'une
partie de la cabane qui est sur un
terrain municipal il ya l'exemple je
peux vous montrer ça c'est l'exemple
d'une patinoire donc ça c'est la cabane
je vais vous montrer aussi candiac c'est
pas juste à pointe claire à candiac mais
je fais une patinoire de vote depuis
deux trois ans le voit devant chez lui
la municipalité non non non non j'ai pas
le droit est ce que c'est une maladie
quand devient maire
et quelques on doit qu'on est devient
tatillon le
bon alors absolument passer le problème
c'est que lorsqu'une réglementation
municipale elle doit être appliquée dès
fois elle doit être appliquée même si la
ville ne veut pas l'appliquer c'est à
dire que la réglementation a été mis à
des mises là pour une bonne raison par
exemple on a peur que lorsque les
enfants jouent au ballon à la fin des
maisons le ballon est dans la vue
l'offre court derrière le ballon une
voiture passe accident fatal alors une
réglementation à partir du moment où la
réglementation est mise en place la
ville l'a pas le droit de la moduler il
faut qu'elle l'enlève ou que la liesse
mais peut pas la moduler en fonction du
client et en fonction de la situation
mais quand ça aucun bon ok vous tuer
vous êtes c'est normal parce que il faut
remonter à l'origine parfois c'est pas
si fous ces réglementations là ils font
font font escale mais mais mais mais
j'ai rapidement exxon est aussi la
réglementation mais aussi gros bon sens
actuellement on vit une pandémie
les gens sont tannés les gens sont
fatigués surtout et la patinoire de
monsieur à candiac et l année
l'inspecteur est jamais passé dans ses
rues probablement cette année il a
décidé de passer il ya eu zéro plainte
et l'on se dit faut que nos jeunes
sortent de la maison arrête de jouer sur
un tel ordinateur puis elle prendre de
l'air le monsieur est voulu faire son
ans a causé court et trop de style fun
avant tout les voisins autour sont
contents c'est sur son terrain privé je
comprends qu'il ya une réglementation
mais en temps de pandémie en effet
beaucoup d'exceptions et là moi je suis
convaincu que cet inspecteur le comme
celui ci à pointe claire ont
certainement pas d'enfant puis vit
peut-être la morosité lui aussi puis
d'avoir des enfants vont exploser mais
ça doit le faire chez un petit peu plus
la ssa company
le corps
[Musique]
était lesté côtés d'annie la wii le oui
bien sûr mais l'inspecteur a pas le
choix le
[Musique]
oui mais la personne qui fait la planète
pourrait poursuivre la ville par exemple
aux clôtures trop un truc qui est jamais
mesuré mais si jamais citoyenneté cdep
de dap et la ville-etat ignore également
pour les clôtures trop si la ville fait
pas appliquer ce règlement c'est elle
qui va se faire poursuivre ceci étant
dit qu'elle l'enlève de règlement
qu'elle allait
absolument
zéro point dans les deux cas que tous
les mecs vous dit qu'on allait vers le
règlement parce que toi qui es la honte
obligé de le suivre oui et qu'on les
enlève parce que ça c'était l'époque où
on disait la rust un espace pour les
voitures on les laisse rouler trop
rapidement d'une part qu'on mettait
dedans de partout pour que les voitures
roulent à 10 km à bien que ça qu'on
laisse des enfants et la changer la
règle en a tellement qu'on peut jouer en
avant en avant mais je t'aime tu rejoues
en avant chez les messieurs les seuls
qui ont une décision passée bas faire
c'est les élus ils sont capables alpha
la prochaine